Alright the first one is definitely decidable.
The RAM runs at least 1,000,000 steps before terminating.
To do that you just run the program and count how many steps it takes.
If it takes at least 1,000,000 steps then we know that it will take
at least 1,000,000 steps before terminating.
We don't actually need to know whether or not it terminates to answer this question,
we just need to know that it runs at least 1,000,000 steps before that might happen.
The RAM runs at least a million steps and will eventually terminate.
That is not decidable.
The reason for that is in order to answer this question we do need to know
whether the program eventually terminates, unlike this first question.
In order to answer that we need to answer the general question of whether
a program will terminate, which we've discussed in the unit is actually undecidable in general.
So this is not decidable.
This final statement is decidable.
It's decidable in much the same way that the first statement is.
The RAM runs at most 1,000,000 steps before terminating.
Well simply count the number of steps it takes and then answer the question.